hey guys dr. Burke here in this video
we're gonna talk about the best times to
eat to lose weight okay this is based on
a technique called intermittent fasting
where you're going for a longer period
of time without eating because what will
happen that will fix a condition called
insulin resistance and that's where your
insulin is too high but it's not working
that well so this in the presence of
insulin you will not lose weight in fact
if you have a belly that's because you
have too much insulin okay so to correct
that we do intermittent fasting now when
you do intermittent fasting and you're
going either to meals or three meals or
one meal whatever don't worry about
losing your muscle you will not lose
your muscle this protects proteins and
muscle in fact it's a good way to
increase testosterone and growth hormone
both fat burning hormones both hormones
that actually help build up muscle so
you're not going to lose muscle by doing
this most people will not be able to do
two meals a day they'll have to start
out with three meals a day but the goal
is to graduate to two meals a day if you
really want to lose some serious weight
but if you have in a minute if you
actually have instant resistance it's
going to be hard to go without eating
because your blood sugars are all messed
up but the goal is what I'm gonna show
you right here okay but you might have
it might take a couple weeks or even a
month to get into this so you might have
to do like startup doing three meals a
day but ideally the best time to eat
would be 11:30 in the morning okay so
you eat 11:30 and then the next time you
eat would be 5 o'clock now if you cannot
do this thence eat at 4:30 so the goal
is at 11:30 to be very very satisfied
when you eat don't just have a little
thing have a good solid meal of protein
greens and some healthy fat okay don't
go a little fat this will it'll mess you
up so you want to adjust the fats to
your very satisfied so you can go from
this meal to this meal if you can't go
from this meal to this meal that means
that you did not have a
enough fat now it's okay to be a little
hungry right about five but if your
ravenously hungry well you're just
having blood sugar issues you're you
have to go back to three meals a day you
haven't graduated yeah so and the
feeling that you're gonna feel is your
stomach is gonna be a lot less bloated
you're gonna feel like your stomach is
shrinking and coming in because you're
burning off that belly fat this is the
best way to lose your belly okay because
basically we're we're Network we're
restoring insulin levels and then at
night same thing protein greens and fat
at five o'clock - you're very very
satisfied so you can go from that point
all the way till the morning all right
now what what do you what are your
concerns maybe you're gonna be starving
about it you know you're not because an
average body has a lot of reserve and
that's I'm talking about fat to live off
of
so you're basically living off of fat
between here in here and here right here
so the goal is to be able to switch when
you're eating you're burning off the
calories from eating and then when
you're not eating switching over to
fat-burning to burn off your own body
fat that whole switch is controlled by
insulin so once you heal this by doing
this you'll be able to do it more and
more and more very easily but it takes a
while to kind of graduate into it I
think the biggest problem with people
doing this or intermittent fasting is
it's such a habit to eat it's such a
routine thing that people snack on foods
when they get home so that is going to
be your biggest barrier to overcome is
breaking the habit of just eating so
frequently
there are huge bodybuilders that I know
that eat once or twice a day they don't
eat all day so and there's really skinny
people that eat you know five meals a
day and well they're they're gonna
actually end up having problems with
this down the road but the point is the
habit to break would be the frequent
eating now this is gonna save you a lot
of money because you're not going to
have to buy as much food so that's a
positive thing and you're also going to
feel a lot healthier your brain your
cognitive function
and you're gonna fix all the other
health problems that are connected to
this so if you're new at this start off
with three meals a day with no snacking
and then graduate into two until you
reach your goal then you can decide if
you want to stick to two or go to three
it really depends on a couple factors
your age if you're younger you're
probably nine eat three meals if you're
exercising like crazy you're going to
need three meals but a lot of people
that are even exercising they do two
meals and they feel incredible and once
you get into fat-burning you're gonna
have a hard time going back to the sugar
running your body on sugar because
you're basically tapping into your own
fuel source and by the way fat burning
or ketosis was the original feel that
our bodies were running on way back so
it was it wasn't till recently that we
started getting into the whole running
our bodies and sugar in probably the
last 100 years so this is a very natural
thing for our bodies our bodies like to
burn fat but we have to practice in a
minute fasting to be able to do this
okay
so it's 11:30 and five o'clock go ahead
and try this and put your comments below